je suis catalan mais seulement la police
nationale vous pouvez nous suivre au
commissariat
ça va prendre combien de temps tu
n'auras pas pour longtemps vous
inquiétez pas
pouvez nous parler un peu du cléo vous
avez chargé j'ai commencé par une course
pour l'aéroport de la base charge d'une
cliente qui allaient à grasse ça vous
plaît peut-être taxi quoi j'aime bien
ça me laisse le temps de réfléchir à
d'autres projets d'autres choses que je
pourrais faire plus tard j'ai fini dans
le centre j'ai téléphoné à ma copine je
dis finalement je passerai pas la voir
avec ce qui s'est passé quelque chose
d'inhabituel
vous pouvez me dire que je sais pas
j'ai tous ses pieds d'être l'auteur d'un
enlèvement d'enfant j'ai rien fait c'est
quoi cette histoire là je vous notifie
donc votre mise en examen monsieur
cazals est pour enlèvement et
séquestration
on a retrouvé votre adn sur le châssis
de la fenêtre par laquelle la fillette a
été enlevée n'y a pas d'erreur possible
vous souvenez vous du fait qu'il vous a
dit qu'il était crevé et et qui
m'expliquerai [ __ ] et l'at il fait où
je parlais à quelqu'un qui leur semblait
un enfant mais c'est non plus n'a pas
cru bon n'oublie rien si j'avais su bien
sûr j'aurais tout raconté que la journée
j'avais enlevé cette petite fille non
c'est non à l'épreuve
arrêter maintenant avec vos cils zinc
dans la assez d'entendre mes conneries à
propos des étudiants qui existent pas
dites moi ce que vous pensez maintenant
dit que
raismes la blache on a retrouvé votre
fille